[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
fact International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends welcome to amazing facts
Bible answers live would you like to
hear an amazing fact Saddam Hussein the
infamous former dictator of Iraq became
obsessed with the ancient Babylonian
ruler Nebuchadnezzar who had conquered
Israel and current Day Iran Saddam saw
himself as a modern Reincarnation of
Nebuchadnezzar who would unite the Arab
world and restore the ancient empire of
Babylon but a Hebrew prophecy in Isaiah
13 clearly states ancient Babylon would
never be rebuilt seeking to prove the
Jewish prediction wrong in 1986 Saddam
spent Millions to reconstruct the old
site of Babylon his delusions came to an
end with his capture following the Gulf
War and eventual execution in
2006 now the ghostly shell of his
immense Palace on a hill above the ruins
of Babylon and the abandoned
construction projects stand as a ghostly
reminder that God's prophecies never
fail well you and I have heard some
stories Pastor Ross about U the Great
Lengths he went to to Tred to
reestablish himself as as the uh ancient
ruler of Babylon he had pictures of him
in Nebuchadnezzar everywhere and he was
riding in a an imitation Chariot of
Nebuchadnezzar and tried to Port portray
himself in reincarnation it wouldn't
make sense with the Islam
theology but he was kind of
fantasizing and he hated Israel so much
that U he thought I can disprove the
prophecy I'll rebuild the ancient city
Construction stopped twice during the
two Gulf Wars and then ultimately it
came to an end and I've heard that uh it
either just happened or will happen soon
that UNESCO is going to declare the
ruins of Babylon a historic site so it
can never be
rebuilt just going to show that God's
prophecy in Isaiah 13 it'll never be
rebuilt it'll never be inhabited I could
not be overthrown you know it's
interesting Pastor when you look at the
Bible you sometimes the Old Testament
it's been described as uh the story of
two cities on the one hand you have
Jerusalem representing you know God's
dwelling place and the truth and way of
Salvation then you got the opposite of
that being Babylon and of course
historically you have the Babylonians
that conquered and destroyed Jerusalem
and took the Jews captive but then God's
people came out of Babylon and rebuilt
the temple and Jerusalem so that same
theme of Babylon and Jerusalem kind of
follows all the way not not only in the
Old Testament but we even see some of
that in the New Testament in the New
Testament you got a whole chapter
talking about a woman this time and her
name is Babylon yeah babylon's actually
mentioned I think six or six times in
the Book of Revelation and uh chapter 17
pretty clearly identifies who Babylon is
it's interesting that even in the New
Testament times the apostles use the
word Babylon to kind of refer to Rome
because the Romans were occupying Israel
like the ionians had once done and um I
better not say too much cuz we've got a
free offer that's going to tell people
about who is Babylon in the Book of
Revelation that's right we've got a book
called The Scarlet woman and the reason
we have that title is because you read
the description in Revelation 17 this
woman Babylon she's dressed in scarlet
and we be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks that is the free uh
offer for this evening called The
Scarlet woman the number to call is 800
83567 47 you can ask for that by name
the scholar woman or dial pound 250 say
Bible anwers live and then ask for that
free offer and we'll send you a digital
download so two ways that you're going
to be able to receive that offer and I
hope you take advantage of it it's a
great read it's an important study
because part of the Three Angels
messages God's last warning message
talks about Babylon being Fallen being
fallen so understanding who babyon is
what it represents that's an important
truth and yeah it's amazing that I I
still run into some Christian pastors
that say oh yeah ancient babylon's going
to be rebuilt they're totally missing
not only the prophecy in Isaiah that
said it would not be but what Revelation
is really talking about so you owe it to
yourself friends to pick up this study
guide you'll be blessed all right well
before before we go to the phone lines
as we always do uh let's stop with
prayer dear father we thank you once
again that we have this time to open up
your word and study and father we always
want to ask your blessing upon this
program wherever the people might be who
are listening we just pray Lord that
You' guide them and be with us here in
the studio as you search the scriptures
to find a clearer understanding of Bible
Truth for we ask this in jesus' name
amen amen we're going to go to the phone
lines we've got Elijah listening in
Arizona and he has a question about the
Judgment Elijah welome to the program
yes um my question was um at the when if
you do something and you repent and you
never do it again and ask God for
forgiveness at the time of judgement
will will God show it to
everyone no if you've repented of your
sins and you've asked God to forgive you
the Bible tells us that he takes our
sins and he casts them into the depths
of the sea I'm trying to remember that
verse I used to know it by heart but if
they're not repented of you can read in
Luke
12:3 wherefore whatever you have spoken
in the dark will be heard in the light
and what you've spoken in the ear in
inner rooms will be proclaimed from the
housetops so the Lord basically says you
know everything is going to be made
manifest and open to the eyes of whom we
have to do but if our sins are forgiven
they're under the blood he buries in the
depths of the sea and he doesn't
remember them anymore he forgives and
forgets our sins so to speak yeah Micah
7: 19 is the verse you're referring to
there all right thank you next caller
that we have is Gary and he's got a
question related to Revelation Gary
welcome to the
program thank you in Revelation 7 it
says the world will end by fire and hail
so we're seeing a lot of weather events
that have that come true are we in the
in Tribulation or are we are just in the
perilous times yeah well I I certainly
do believe Gary that we are seeing an
acceleration of natural disasters I've
actually got a chart where insurance
companies of course they make their
money and insuring against disasters
there they show that all different kinds
of dis dister seem to be on the increase
now of course you know they're blaming
global warming for that and other things
but um I don't think we're in the great
time of trouble because that's when the
seven last plagues fall I think we're in
a time that's leading up to what you
call the small time of trouble you know
Jesus said there's going to be Wars
rumors of wars earthquakes in different
places but the end isn't yet and so
these things accelerate like labor pains
get closer together before a woman has a
baby you see greater fre quency greater
intensity that's where we're at now you
know Luke 21:25 Jesus talking about an
time events he says there'll be signs in
the sun and the moon and the stars and
on the earth distress of nations with
perplexity and then it adds this the Sea
and the waves roaring kind of gives the
idea of an increase of storms or
increase of you know weather issues and
yeah as we get closer to the end it
seems that we see more of that all right
thank you Gary we've got Karen in
Nebraska and she's got a question about
um mlisc Karen welcome to the
program hi thank you um I'm studying
Hebrews and I'm having a hard time with
chapter 7 um okay I understand it's
about the priesthood and it's talking
about the order of mzc and the Order of
Aaron and the law and the Covenant but I
thought we didn't know even know who MDC
is how does that fit in here in chapter
7 I think but Paul We Believe wrote
Hebrews Paul is showing that he
melkisedek who appears in the Old
Testament is an allegory of Christ um
you know most of the priests came from
the tribe of Aaron but Paul is saying
there were some Priests of God that
didn't come from Israel at all such as
melkisedek when you look in the Old
Testament it says four or five
interesting things about melkisedek
first of all it doesn't say where he
came from we know he was a king of Salem
that later became known as jerus Salem
which means city of peace and um Jesus
is our king of Peace of the New
Jerusalem it says he the word melkisedek
means king of righteousness Jesus is our
king of righteousness he brought Abraham
Bread and Wine and Jesus made the
Covenant with the bread and the wine
with the disciples and so there's a lot
of analogies of melchisedec who is a
king and a priest Jesus is our high
priest and our King so Paul is showing
that he was a type of Christ who is
without beginning or end there we don't
know what happened to melkisedek he
appears and disappears in the Bible we
don't know his genealogy so that's why
Paul is saying all that he's also laying
the foundation that Christ's priesthood
his Heavenly Ministry is superior to
that of the levitical priesthood because
obviously Jesus didn't come through the
tribe of Levi he came through the tribe
of Judah so someone said well how can he
be a priest if he's not part of the
tribe of Levi Paul is making the
argument in Hebrew saying well he's
actually part or a symbol mesic is a
symbol or a type of Christ priesthood
which is even greater than that of the
levitical priesthood because Abraham
gave a tithe to mlisc so that's his
argument he's kind of portraying this
High Priestly Ministry of Jesus far
superior to that of the uh the Hebrew or
the levitical priesthood you got a good
series on Hebrews I shouldn't let you
answer that oh no no that's a good gave
a good answer that's a great study it
really is all right thank you Karen uh
we got Glen listening in Ohio question
about uh Acts CH 2 Glenn welcome to the
program good evening thank you very much
for taking my call yeah now historically
Christianity is not a religion that was
practiced till about four four centuries
after the apostles if that's the case
what Doctrine did the apostles adhere to
in Acts
2:42 then if the statement about the
history of Christianity is not true when
did Christianity come on the scene and
where did the name come
from well it tells us they first called
them Christians it's right in the Bible
it in the book of Acts it says they
first called them Christians in Antioch
so that's back in the days of the
Apostles so I'm not sure where you heard
that the religion of Christianity did
not begin until four centuries after
Christ the organized Catholic Church may
not have begun until that point but
Christianity began in the Old Testament
and that verse you talking about Pastor
I acts 11:26 where it says as you
mentioned in Antioch the Believers were
called Christians so that's kind of the
origin of the name and of course the
early church for the first 100 years
they were taught by the apostles who
were taught by Christ directly right so
the church was growing it was
Evangelistic they were faithful to the
word uh and yeah it wasn't until the
legalization of Christianity in 313 and
the rise of the uh papal power the
Catholic church that we begin to see
some compromise taking place yeah where
the church began to wander away from the
simple truths of the Bible Church was
organized even in in Acts chapter 6
they're appointing deacons and then
they're having Paul is appointing elders
and they had a council in Jerusalem yeah
so they were they didn't maybe have a
big um Vatican but they certainly were
an organized religion at that point okay
thank you Glen good question Glenn we
got Nicole listening in Michigan and
she's asking about the day of atonement
Nicole Welcome to the
program hi good evening how are you good
how are you good my question is um when
Babylon came and destroyed Jerusalem I
mean the um the sanctuary um The Ark was
taken and hidden so when Nehemiah and
Ezra went back to rebuild the city and
they started to perform the various
ceremonies mainly the day of atonement
how are they keeping the day of
atonement if the Ark of the Covenant was
not in the most holy Place good question
and you know there's all I have on that
is speculation and I've never read
anything definitive but you're right the
real Ark the original Ark that was made
during the time of Moses captured once
by the Philistines recovered then when
Nebuchadnezzar came and besieged the
city it was hidden somewhere and it's
probably still hidden there and no
Solomon did not give it to the queen
asba as our Ethiopian friends say
because it appears again later during
the time of King Joseph mesiah but as
near as we can tell when they rebuilt
the temple they put some uh faximile of
the Ark in there so that the priest
could put blood on it during the day of
atonement but they were hoping that God
would restore to them the place of the
original Arc so I don't think they ever
made a copy of it at least I don't see
any record of that but they had they put
I think some kind of fa simile of it
with Golden Horn so they could put the
blood on it right of course what made
the Ark of the Covenant so special was
the LW written by the finger of God on
the tables of stone inside the ark that
could never be reproduced so they had
like you say maybe a box of some kind or
something to kind of represent where it
stood in the most holy Place yep okay
thanks Nicole good question we got uh
Dana listening in New York and she's
calling about uh what does the Bible say
about praise dancing Dana welcome to the
program yes hi how are you all doing
doing very well thank you all right God
bless you both so my question is um what
do you think about modern praise dancing
where some Churches may have an
individual or group mostly females um
dressed in a long dress of some sort and
then they perform different bodily
movements to a gospel song what do you
think about that form of worship and is
it biblical well you're asking is it
biblical uh there's only three or four
examples of dancing now the word dance
is mentioned more than three or four
times but you've got of course where
David danced before the ark that was not
in the temple or on the Sabbath day he's
bringing the ark up to the house of God
uh then you have when the women came out
uh following a victory like when David
and Saul beat the Philistines the women
came out and sang songs and that was
customary that they'd go out and greet
and celebrate uh a victory when Mariam
led the women after crossing the Red Sea
because of the victory over the
Egyptians they would sing the women only
dance with women this is not happening
in the sanctuary the ones who let out in
praise and music music in the sanctuary
were typically the Levites and the sons
of Asaf which were I think Levites if
I'm not mistaken they were the musicians
I was reading about that this week in 1
Chronicles I think
25 um but I don't see any example of
women dancing or recreating songs in the
temple on the Sabbath and the type of
dancing as you mentioned Pastor D he
very different even from what we see
today in some Churches uh even today if
you go to Israel and you go to the
waiting wall even on Friday evening or
on the Sabbath you'll have two groups
you have the men on the one side you
have the woman on the other side and
they usually form a circle and they'll
sing and they'll move around in a circle
that's a little different than having
four or five people standing on the
stage you know waving a banner or moving
around to music with a scarf or
something it's it's tot it was a totally
different type type of Celebration yeah
yeah the focus in Israel at the whing
wall of course that's not even in the
temple that's in the wall outside the
focus there was really just to welcome
the Sabbath and they usually were
singing a um some kind of a Biblical
Song it was a usually repeating some
biblical promis or
song yeah uh I've seen this before I
know just what you're talking about and
it kind of it I just couldn't picture
that happening in the synagogue of of
Jesus anyway uh thanks I appreciate your
question all right next caller that we
have is junith listening in Nevada and
she's asking about haar junith welcome
to the program hi hello hiom and good
evening to both of you thanks for taking
my call my question is what could have
happened that Hagar and abraam did not
have Ishmael okay well if Ishmael was
not in the picture um of well of course
if Sarah did not encourage Abraham to
use Hagar as a surrogate I guess it was
more than a surrogate a concubine um
well then Isaac would have been born and
a lot of the problems that are in the
world today between the descendants of
Ishmael and the descendants of Isaac
would probably not be happening if
you're asking what if higar did not have
a
child well then again it would probably
be a non-event eventually Sarah would
have so whenever you say what if you
start to speculate and you can go wild
trying to speculate how God would have
orchestrated things because you really
don't know mhm people say what would
have happened if Eve ate the fruit in
Adam
didn't you ever heard that one mhm yeah
so I don't even try to answer
that you lose every time we don't know
all right well thank you junith we've
got Julie in South Dakota she's got a
question about the close of probation
Julie welcome to the
program well thank you appreciate you
taking my call um I was wondering if
there's a correlation between the
closing of probation with God shutting
the door to Noah's Ark um seven days
prior to the rain because I was thinking
maybe like seven years prior to Jesus
returning that God would you know close
the door to Salvation and we could no
longer be saved during those seven years
well is there a correlation there is in
the sense that life went on outside the
ark for a period of time even after
their Destiny was sealed I don't think
the seven days of Noah because it's not
a prophecy are representing seven years
for one thing can you imagine what the
world would look like after one year of
the oceans and fresh water being blood
and men being scorched with great heat
and people suffering with a noisome sore
I think the time for the seven plagues
is going to be more like the time of the
10 plagues that fell on Egypt when you
track that it probably happened within a
period of about a month a month and a
half it came in quick order like the
plagues that fell on job it seemed like
they came rather quickly lasted a few
weeks and um so I don't see the seven
last plagues when probation closes
there's really no purpose in God
allowing the world to suffer for seven
years with the righteous still here uh
surrounded with that misery there's no
they can't be lost there's no benefit no
one's being converted yeah we do have a
verse on that also Revelation 18:8 easy
verse to remember it's talking about the
plagues so that we know the plagues come
after pration closes it says therefore
her plagues speaking of Babylon will
come in one day death and mourning and
famine and she shall be utterly burned
with fire so the Bible seems to indicate
that yes once probation closes and the
plagues begin to fall uh once the
plagues start falling it's about the
period of a of a year and if you look at
the makeup of the plagues like you say
the Earth probably can't keep going much
longer if all of this you know the
plagues are falling and like you say the
sea turning to blood the fresh waters
turning to blood there's famine intense
heat fires so all right hopefully that
helps thank you next caller that we have
is Wade in Minnesota Wade welcome to the
program you have a question about second
Thessalonians yeah thank you um yeah I'm
trying to figure out uh who the he is in
2 Thessalonians 2:7 and when that verse
will be
fulfilled yeah let's read this for our
friends that are listening speaking of
uh we believe the Antichrist power it
says for the mystery of lawlessness is
already at work he who now restrains
will do so until he is taken out of the
way so he is capital H the holy spirit
is going to restrain the work of the the
devil the Lawless one uh so are you're
wondering about the he there who does
the restraining I believe that's the
spirit is that your understanding yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah so the holy spirit
is restraining and uh you can read in
the days of Noah when wickedness
increased in the earth God's spirit was
restraining it says my spirit will not
always strive with men there'll come a
day when once again the spirit will be
withdrawn and no longer strive with
people and then kind of demons have free
reign at that point and it's going to
get pretty uh hairy scary on the world
at that time all right thank you next
call the we have is Ryan in New Mexico
Ryan welcome to the program hello how
y'all doing today doing good thank you
for calling my question is isn't the
7-Day cycle have Babylonian roots that
started from it would be sun worship all
right well let's talk about that the it
is true the Babylonians also recognize a
7-Day week most of the world well
everyone of the world recognizes a 7-Day
week now uh the Babylonians they worship
the son on the first day of the week and
then Egypt also the son was the
principal God of worship with the Greeks
and the Romans it was Apollo Jupiter um
so and that's why you get the word
Sunday so in that sense the Sunday part
of the Babylonian worship uh trickled
down through other Empires and when we
were talking about Babylon earlier Not
only was there a war between Israel and
Babylon but you go back to the Tower of
Babel MH and uh you know it it you can
see two camps actually split way back
then but um the weekly cycle begins in
Genesis where God creates the world in
six days and then he creates another day
as a day of rest that we call the
seventh day in the
Sabbath that didn't come from the
Babylonians that the Bible tells us that
goes all the way back to the beginning
and it's not just the son God that was
worshiped you know for one day during
the week of course you have Monday which
is connected with the moon God and so
you know all of these pagan traditions
and cultures they would look to the
heavens and they'd see these different
planets and they would name them a God
and they'd worship them on a specific
day but what's amazing is that they also
followed a 7-Day week 7-Day cycle and
there's nothing in the natural realm you
know it's not because the Earth is
spinning on its you know Axis or it's
going around the Sun or the moon all of
you know you talk about years and you
got months uh and you got days uh we we
can see something in nature but when it
comes to the 7-Day week the only
evidence for that although only reason
for that is back in Genesis chapter 1
yep absolutely well thank you appreciate
that maybe we have time for another call
before our break all right we've got uh
James listening in Texas James welcome
to the
program yes sir hi thank you for taking
my call
tonight my question is does God have a
does God have a sin like in I've read in
Exodus chapter 20:
3-5 where it does say even guy come um
says himself that he that he is a
jealous God but but ain't jealousy a sin
good good question yeah God says I'm a
jealous God and this is an emotion that
is appropriate if a man is married he
loves his wife and he feels no
protection or possessiveness if someone
is infringing on the relationship that
is unnatural When God says he's a
jealous God it means he loves us and
he's not willing to share that love with
another God or an idol
that is normal that is healthy and so
some people are obsessed with uh
inappropriate jealousy they just not
trusting their spouse when there's no
reason for distrust that's inappropriate
so we think about a person who's you
know jealous that someone else is
prospering that's inappropriate but um
the biblical je jealousy that you would
have in a love relationship is normal
and acceptable this is what God is
talking about okay very good well I'm
looking at the clock P it I we've got 20
seconds before we're going to take a
break of course the program's not over
we just halfway through Best Is Yet To
Come that's that's right so friend stand
by we'll be call your friends tell them
you know we still got a half an hour to
answer your Bible questions and we will
be back in just a few moments we'll take
a break and then answer more Bible
[Music]
questions stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly have you always want wanted to
be a Bible expert but never knew where
to start are you searching for answers
that will bring you joy peace and
fulfillment then you'll love the amazing
facts storical of Prophecy Bible study
experience now available in 18 languages
featuring 24 easyto read lessons the
storical are packed with scripture and
step-by-step guidance that will give you
absolute confidence about what the Bible
actually says about the second coming
the Rapture the Antichrist Christ and
the mark of the beast you'll also get
the truth about hell and the afterlife
and practical insight about Grace
salvation and how to truly live like
Jesus even better it's absolutely free
at storical dorg so don't miss out get
started on your Bible study Adventure
today at storical
dorg Can't Get Enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing faxx media
library at aftv.org at aftv.org you can
enjoy video and audio presentations as
well as printed material all free of
charge 24 hours a day 7 days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
the lifechanging book steps to Christ
has has introduced Millions around the
world to the real Jesus and now you can
share it powerfully with two new
beautiful additions designed by amazing
facts the pathway to piece Edition
features 14 amazing fact study guides
footsteps A Closer Walk With Jesus to
learn more about mass mailing these
resources to your entire Community call
7275 or visit AF bookstore.com did you
know amazing fact has a free by school
that you can do from the comfort of your
own home it includes 27 beautifully
Illustrated study lessons to Aid in your
study of God's word sign up today for
this free Bible study course by calling
21570 that's 1844
257000 Jerusalem the city of Peace has
been a place of unending Conflict for
centuries many now believe that
Jerusalem will soon take Center Stage
again but what does the Bible say the
fall and Rise of Jerusalem presents the
vital history you need to know about
Jerusalem and its role in Endtime Bible
prophecy this amazing facts edition of
the classic volume the great controversy
is the perfect sharing book get your
copy at AF bookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
700 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835 6747
once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers live we are back welcome
friends again to Bible answers live if
you're tuning in along the way we are a
live International interactive Bible
study we're not only on radio station
satellite landbase we are streaming on
the amazing facts Facebook page the Doug
Bachelor Facebook YouTube channel and uh
a number of other outlets and we're just
so thankful that we could be studying
the word with you my name is Doug
Bachelor my name is John Ross and we've
got Jay in Canada that is standing by
with a question about 1 Timothy Chapter
2 Jay welcome to the
program yeah so my question is for that
verse it says uh I do not permit a woman
to teach or to have Authority for over a
man she must remain silent my question
is is that just for the col of the day
or is that still applied today maybe
only in the church or just applied today
in general no I think that generally
speaking in spiritual matters Paul's not
saying that you know in a marriage there
there are areas in domestic life where
women are in charge you know Karen I
have a a a good working relationship
there are certain things that she does
and certain things that I do and she is
the chief of certain areas but when it
comes to being the priest of the family
spiritual leader and the church is an
extension church is a combination of
families men are to are supposed to be
the spiritual leaders in their
households now in the case where a woman
becomes a Believer and she's married to
an unbeliever she will need to take the
lead on teaching the children the word
but in a regular uh Christian family the
man should be taking the lead and you
only see men offering sacrifice and
fulfilling the Priestly functions in the
Bible so there is a distinction in roles
but does that mean a woman can never
speak in the church no because we have
examples in the Bible where women did
speak but it's talking about having
teaching the authority the final
Authority was to rest with the men also
if you read on a little further in the
chapter Paul talks about having all
things done decently and in order it
appears that there were some issues that
were been addressed especially in the
Church of Corinth where there was a
little bit of chaos from time to time it
seems in the church where people were
talking over other people and there was
too much noise and uh perhaps the woman
in the in the group in the church were
calling down to their men who was
sitting in a different area and Paul is
saying no let's let's keep reverent
let's do everything decent and in order
and uh you know this is not the time to
talk back and forth during the service I
know it probably surprises people you
and I traveled a lot we've been in
churches where in the Middle East in
India the men and women do not sit
together and objectively they're
figuring you know keep your mind pure so
they separate them and women in Corinth
were maybe calling across the the aisle
so to speak or up to the balcony and uh
asking their husbands questions kind of
embarrassing their husbands and Paul
said talk at home don't don't do that
here yeah in other words they were
calling down to their husband did you
hear that are you listening yeah pay
attention all right next caller that we
have is Amanda in Nebraska uh Amanda
welcome to the program hello hi thanks
for calling yeah I just had a question
on Leviticus 1923 through 25 do you have
any idea what that significance could be
yeah let me read that for our friends
when you come into the land and you've
planted all kinds of trees for food then
you shall Count Their fruit as
uncircumcised three years it shall be
uncircumcised you it shall not be eaten
but in the fourth year all the fruit
shall be holy a praise to the Lord in
the fifth year you may eat its fruit and
it may yield to you its increase I am
the Lord your God that imp particular or
are you talking about the I think that's
the main one you're talking about is
that right
Amanda yeah yeah yeah the I know that
not sure what that yeah I I I know that
may seem a little odd but they're
actually uh trees that start bearing
fruit they just like a lot of creatures
they have a
maturity where the fruit will be I think
the best after a few years of bearing um
if you strip a tree too much when it's
young it also can't might not survive it
it's almost like it needs to uh grow a
little bit and then you're going to have
the best fruit there may be a spiritual
analogy to that often the first fruits
belong to the Lord when it came to
animals giving birth and so this may
have been something where they said you
know take the fruit give it to the
creatures but it belongs to the Lord the
first few years and it actually the
promisees it'll produce even more fruit
yeah and we know that if the plant has a
chance to kind of you know those first
few years it's important so there's
practical reasons but also it's a
recognition that everything comes from
God he provides food for us sustains us
so it's dual application I think dual
meaning there thank you Amanda we've got
Ellen listening in North Carolina and
she's got a question about the second
commandment Ellen welcome to the
program oh hi thank you so much pastors
for taking my call I just have to thank
you we my family has learned so much
from this program thank you for this
ministry the second commandment pretty
basic and I'm having trouble um I know
Jesus said you know remember me and he
was a man so and also with um you know
different uh teachings and even in uh
Sunday school for the children or
Saturday school for the children with
kids stories and pictures of Jesus
movies of Jesus The Ten Commandments
could you speak about that please in
terms of what it says in Deuteronomy in
the second
commandment yes it's in both Deuteronomy
and in Exodus where you find the Ten
Commandments and let me just read it for
our friends you'll not make for yourself
a carved image any likeness of anything
in the heaven above or that is in the
earth beneath or that is in the water
under the Earth You shall not bow down
yourself to them nor serve them for I
the Lord your God I'm a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers on
the children unto the third and fourth
generations of those that hate me but
showing mercy and thousands of those who
love me and keep my Commandments uh God
did not want us making images of
anything and worshiping it this is not a
complete or comprehensive prohibition
about making any kind of a likeness of
anything by itself it's a not make a
likeness and bow down to it proof for
that would be a little later uh you see
in the Bible where God instructs Moses
to make a bronze Serpent of all things
Jesus even refers to that they looked at
it and they were live they were healed
from the Venom when Solomon built the
temple he put this great big bronze
bathtub that held the water for the
priest to wash it wasn't for their them
to climb in it was on 12 oxen now they
weren't to pray to The Oxen and they all
knew that it was just ornamental in the
sanctuary God told them that they were
to engrave Angels on the walls of the
Holy place and in the veil so God
wouldn't say don't do this don't make
any kind of a likeness of anything uh or
you'll be killed and then say now don't
forget to make images of Cherub them on
top of the Ark there're two angels on
top of the Ark the key is we shouldn't
have prayed these things now there is a
risk you know I think whenever we start
making representations or failes or
paintings or statues of Jesus some
people are you not like
inclined uh to pray to those things or
think there's some kind of a sacred
Relic during the time of Hezekiah when
the people started burning incense to
the bronze serpent that somehow had
survived all those years he said that's
just a piece of brass and he crushed it
and threw it away just like Moses
crushed the golden calf and said don't
drink the water don't worship these
things so um I don't know if that helps
a little bit uh but um yeah it's it it's
not a sin to make a representation of
something we need to be careful if
people
are
um I know I'm kind of hemming and hawing
here because I sure don't want to lead
anyone wrong I was with Karen in Russia
it's interesting the Catholic Church
prays the statues but in the Orthodox
Church they pray the
paintings and and we brought as gifts to
Russia paintings from The Book of
Revelation because we were doing a
revelation seminar when the pastors saw
that they kind of rolled their eyes
thinking what's happened to the American
church because they tell their people he
said these folks are going to pin that
up on the wall and put a candle in front
of it and they're going to pray to this
picture uh that you've got from The Book
of Revelation and I thought oh man I
don't want to do anything to make anyone
stumble so you got to keep that in mind
as well you know a lot of good Christian
people might have a picture of Jesus or
the Last Supper on the wall and they
don't pray to it and it it's not any
kind of a relic it's a piece of art so
there's a balance there but if you have
any doubts do the safe thing okay thank
you very much next caller that we have
is Paul in Australia and he has a
question about John chapter 8 vers 56
Paul welcome to the program thank you
thank you so much for answering my call
U my question is uh my my question is uh
John 8 verse 56
said to the Jews that is the Abram your
father ABR you see my day I rejoy so
which mean that is ABR in the heaven or
or is not in the heaven if in the heaven
why the Bible is not accorded and if
it's not in the heaven why did youus say
that yeah when Jesus said Abraham saw my
day and he rejoiced your father Abram
rejoiced to see that means he rejoiced
looking forward to his day when Abraham
took his son up on the mountain and
offered his only begotten son he didn't
quite complete the offering because an
angel stopped him God I think revealed
to Abraham I am going to give my son and
Abraham understood that God so loved the
world he would give his son he saw
Abraham then saw on Mount Mariah the day
of Christ's coming he understood what
the mission of Christ was and he
rejoiced it doesn't mean Abraham was up
in heaven looking down and rejoicing cuz
Abraham's dead he's sleeping until the
resurrection so it says Abraham
slept so one might say that Abraham saw
it in Vision perhaps yeah God revealed
to him what was yet to come yeah yeah
exactly okay very good well thank you
thanks Paul hopefully that helps we've
got Joseph in Florida and Joseph is
asking a question about Matthew chapter
18 uh Joseph welcome to the
program hi thank you for taking my call
yeah um the question I had was when when
pet had asked Jesus how many times
should I uh forgive my brother and he
said up to seven times thinking that
that was you know the the limit or the
ultimate and Jesus referred um no stimes
70 that was see reflecting to the 70 we
prophecy the 490 day year prophecy of
Daniel 9:24 that God had allotted to the
Jewish Nation to repent you know that's
very perceptive because
Daniel in chapter 9 is praying and God
had been so merciful with the nation
he's wondering how long uh in you know
will you bear with your people because
he God answers and says 70 weeks are cut
off for the nation there would be 70
times s 490 years of Mercy now and um
you find sev's often associated with
forgiveness it says God casts Seven
Devils out of Mary Magdalene a righteous
man falls seven times times and rises
again job says he will deliver me in six
times yes seven no evil will befall me
so the number seven is often associated
with perfect forgiveness which is
probably why Peter said seven times but
Jesus said no 70 * 7 now God is not in
heaven with a ledger that is counting
how many times you sin because all of us
listening probably would have used up
our 490 times a long time ago he's
basically saying that as long as we're
willing to genuinely repent he will
forgive so um yeah beautiful thought but
I I do think there's kind of an illusion
there he's making that's right sort of
there is a probationary time coming yeah
yep forgiveness does end at some point
all right thank you we've got Chelsea in
Florida Chelsea welcome to Bible ances
live hi good evening how are you both
good so my question is how do I explain
to other Christians of different
denominational backgrounds
basically the importance of studying
biblical doctrines like the truth about
hell the second coming um and also if
they've never been exposed to like the
Three Angels message and the truth in
Revelation um like for example like if
we're studying the truth about Hellfire
and then like maybe if someone says well
these details don't really matter it
just matters if we all believe in Jesus
Christ and that he's our savior and
that's it we don't have to you really
study the details so how do I explain
the importance of these doctrines to
them well that's a great question and uh
I was exercising my mind about that just
last week in visiting with some friends
um and yeah a a lot of Christians will
say well as long as we love the Lord and
it is true that love for God is Premier
and there are going to be Christians for
many faiths in heaven but understanding
Doctrine affects our picture of God for
example
the unbiblical teaching that the wicked
burn through ceaseless ages for the sins
of one
lifetime it distorts a picture of God
and makes him look like he is unjust and
he enjoys watching his creatures suffer
there is a hell and there is a
punishment and people need to understand
that but the idea that zillions of years
go by and they've never even begun
burning is just a horrific thought when
you think about it and the Bible doesn't
teach that so understanding the truth
about that Doctrine
uh actually sets you free and Jesus said
the truth will set you free so I I would
tell people that misunder understanding
the
particulars changes their ability to
love God they can love him more when
they understand the truth and then also
I think it's important for us to realize
that as we near the end of time the
truths that have been revealed in
scripture and especially in Prophecy are
extremely important to help us so we are
not deceived because the Jesus said in
the last days there' be many false
prophets and many false christs and they
deceive many so we need to test
everything by the word of God and so
understanding these important truths
will be a safeguard to help us in the
last days in particular for example
before Jesus came the first time yeah
people had different ideas but if you if
you didn't understand the nature of
Christ first coming meaning that he was
going to come as a savior and you
thought he's going to come as a
conquering King if you misunderstood how
Christ was going to come well you very
likely would reject him yeah so at the
last days you know understanding how
Jesus will come and the scenes connected
with that becomes very important because
we don't want to be set up by the devil
um impersonating the second coming of
Jesus good point yeah person if not
knowing the truth about that Doctrine
can set them up for a major deception
absolutely hope that helps thank you
chelse see a good good point all right
we've got Jordan in uh Georgia Jordan
welcome to the program I just had a
question on how do I study the Bible um
and like take notes and stuff like that
that's well that's a good question
everyone does it a little different um I
know Karen when she's listening to a
sermon she's got a separate pad she
takes notes and she sticks them in her
Bible and her Bible it ends up being
twice its original size because she's
inserting papers all the time um some
people when they're studying the Bible I
have a a colorcoded it's like a pencil
that's got three or four different uh
colored crayons in it that I can click
down and I underline and the different
colors mean different things so as I'm
preaching it helps me highlight and then
I take a pencil and I write in the
margin a few words um so that helps me
in my Bible study we use Bible Software
uh I use a program called logos where I
can actually make notes in the software
that will reappear later so I save my
notes and you can copy them and back
them up so you don't ever lose them and
um so some people now are transferring a
lot of this study to digital notes in
Bible study and that's actually
computers have accelerated my study
ability a 100 times from when I started
you know I've got a whole bunch of stuff
on my computer but the most important
file that I got on my computer are all
of the sermon notes and the study notes
over the years I make sure I back that
up on the cloud because I don't want to
lose that I like to study and I like to
do cross reference I like to read
commentaries on the different verses and
then kind of condense it down to a
central thought of of what's the
takeaway from that verse so to speak and
then I like to keep that together so
find something that works and it'll
enhance your Bible study yeah some
people take more notes some people
actually use a recorder when I'm driving
down the road I have a tape recorder an
oldfashioned little handheld tape
recorder and I record thoughts that come
to because I know I'll forget by the
time I get
home all right thank you next caller
that we have is Cindy and she is
listening in uh Florida Cindy welcome to
Bible his
life thank you pastors I appreciate your
ministry I've been watching um Pastor
Ross on my YouTube on Sabbath School on
Daniel and pentacostal prophecy I
watched um Dr um Dr Pastor Bachelor so
my question in general is regarding
Daniel and
Revelation why did Christ in Prophecy
Ed um like animals the Rams the goat the
beer the bear the um yeah earthw all
those right the different symbols well
two things one he uses the symbols
because most of the apocalyptic
prophecies were written while God's
people were captive with under another
Nation you had for instance uh Babylon
had uh occupied the Jews when Daniel had
his prophecies and some of the
prophecies talk about the fall of
Babylon so those those things are
couched in symbols babylon's a lion for
example by the way when they excavated
Babylon they found lions with wings on
the walls which is what they saw in
Vision then another thing to keep in
mind is the Israelites were shepherds it
was a nation of shepherds to begin with
so when it's talking about the the the
sheep and the Goat that are fighting
those are clean animals then you get to
the bear the leopard the lion those are
unclean animals there's actually meaning
there as well so
um you know these common animals were
used as
symbols and uh you know in the Bible a
lamb of course a type of Christ water
represented a multitude of people Stormy
Waters represented times of trouble um
these symbols are given other places
Jesus said that um I speak to you in
Parables that the the WIS will
understand he wants us to dig a little
bit and of course some of the things
that are revealed in Prophecy had to do
with kingdoms that were in power at the
time so for example if you go to the
first century early Christian Church
there are things revealed in Bible
prophecy that probably those uh who were
in power had they clearly understood it
it might have brought even more
persecution so it was couched in
symbolism that the wise would understand
it those who are studying but those who
shouldn't know about it didn't
understand it and that was true all
through the Middle Ages through the Dark
Ages
hope helps a little all right next
caller that we have is let's see we've
got uh Janet in California Janet welcome
to the program hi yeah my question is so
if you're saved and when you die you go
to heaven and when people die a lot of
people say that okay they're in heaven
now and they're with other loved ones or
friends or whatever but in the Bible
when it talks about Jesus coming back
for his people it says how the dead will
go and then the living so where are you
really when you're dead de yeah well
you're very perceptive it's a a lot of
misunderstandings about this you know
you read that passage in 2 Corinthians
where it says to be absent from the
bodies to be present with the Lord and
for a Believer your next conscious
thought when you die is the resurrection
but it hasn't happened yet so the dead
are not up there now roaming around
looking down on us Bible tells us in
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 the living know
they'll die the dead don't know
anything David says in Psalms the dead
do not praise the Lord Hezekiah repeats
something similar the the Jesus said our
friend Lazarus is asleep so when a
person dies they are sleeping a
dreamless sleep with no consciousness of
time so for them the next conscious
thought if they're saved is the second
coming the trumpet blows they come out
of the graves right now they are resting
in peace that's why you get that on the
Tombstones that used to say R rip
resting in peace so um until the
Resurrection The judgment hasn't
happened yet so for the Lord to take
people and put them in Heaven or Hell
before the resurrection and before the
judgment and then pull them out again to
judge them wouldn't make any sense what
confuses people is they forget that God
Lives outside of Time For Us in this
world the resurrection hasn't happened
people are asleep the Bible says those
that in their graves will hear his voice
and come forth where are they they're in
their graves until the resurrection C so
we have a study guide we can send a free
copy of that to Janet and anyone who
wants to know about that subject yeah
just call the number 8835
6747 and you can ask for the study guide
It's called are the Dead really dead
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks that's 800 835 6747 you
can also dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live ask
for the study guide are the Dead really
dead and we can send it to you digitally
so you'll be able to read it right along
we also have a website called Death
truth.com that's filled with a lot of
great studies and resources and sermons
so take a look at that all right thank
you uh do we have Patty on the line
Patty and
Idaho hi hi pastors Hi how are
you good good I have a question I think
I'm really trying to gain some better
understanding of God's character is my
question but Revelation 7 or 17 says he
is coming with the clouds every eye will
see him even those who pierced him and
so my question is is it I guess I
operate under the idea that those who
Pierce them are not saved so they should
be a part of the second Resurrection
after the Millennium but he does a
special or what seems to me a special
Resurrection for those which I know
God's character is perfect but me as a
human when I read this I can't help but
think it's boastful yeah well well I I I
do believe that when the Lord comes
there is a special Resurrection Jesus
said at his trial to the high priest
here after you will see the son of man
coming and the Clouds Of Glory on the
right hand of power so there will be
some who are raised that actually see
that and it's like a special
Resurrection it's an exception but it's
also just in response to the demand they
wanted evidence they said are you the
Christ and they kept pushing him and
finally Jesus said well if you want
evidence you'll get it you'll see me
coming in the Clouds Of Glory yes
absolutely you know Pastor Ross we don't
have time to uh run another question
before we take our break some people may
not know that we um we take the break in
in two sections here we have some who
are listening on satellite radio and
they sign off on a different clock than
those who are on land base stations for
those who are on the landbase stations
if you stay by we're going to take a few
moments and go through some rapid fire
Bible questions that come in on the
internet and if you have those questions
we're going to tell you how to send them
in in just a moment for the rest of you
God bless if you've not made your
decision to make Jesus Lord of your life
do that now we'll be
back thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live those of you are able to
stay by for our email questions if you'd
like to send us a question viia email
the email address is just simply B
questions amazingfacts.org
BL questions amazingfacts.org Pastor D
first question tonight why do we wear
shoes in church if being in the presence
of God is on Holy
Ground well there are a few exceptions
in the Bible when it tells us that God
told Joshua and he told Moses take your
shoes off you're on Holy Ground they
were in the physical presence of the uh
Christ uh and God's glory at that time
um it doesn't tell us that the Levites
were to take their shoes off when they
went into the temple and you know they
were ministering for the Lord so um the
high priest may have done that when he
went in on the holy days on the what do
you call the day of atonement but um I
think on dayto day they were you know
busy butchering animals and stuff some
countries do if that's the custom for
respect I'd say do whatever they do you
and I were at a church in India that had
um over 100,000 members in several
Services they all took off their shoes
before they came in it was really and
they managed most of them got their
shoes back after the service so I'd say
whatever do whatever is respectful okay
another question that we have can you
explain the Rapture of the
church yeah well God is not going to
Rapture the church separately
from when he raptures the Saints some
people think that from Revelation 4 on
is uh the church goes to heaven when it
says I saw a door open in heaven I
respectfully disagree I don't think
that's what is happening there in
Revelation CH 4 several things in
revelation after chapter 4 describe the
church in the world it's not just
talking about Israel and so um the idea
that the church is going to be raptured
and saved from tribulation uh that's a
pleasant thought but my Bible says he
that endures to the end will be saved
and that God's people are going to be
saved through tribulation not from
tribulation and I think we even have a
book on that if they read anything but
secret you can ask for a free copy of
anything but secret and that will
explain that subject all right last
question do you think Judas the scariot
would have been forgiven if he repented
after the
resurrection well of course he killed
himself before the resurrection but um I
think if he had sincerely repented Jesus
would have forgiven him but he had
grieved away the Holy Spirit there in
the upper room he kind of had his last
chance when Jesus offered to wash his
feet and the Bible says that Satan
entered him he went out and it was night
friends don't let that happen to you and
God willing we're going to be studying
his word again next week Keep Jesus
first in your life and we'll get
together and uh go to amazingfacts.org
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
h